30 B d'ailleurs j'étais au milieu quand
tu es au milieu parce que le B qui est
au milieu c'est horrible t'as pas de
hublot tu as deux gars et là il y a la
bataille des arcs
les gars c'est un truc de ouf tout de
suite c'est tout de suite c'est dès que
vous arrivez il faut mettre les deux
s'imposer on les accoudoirs là et là
normalement il y a une meuf un mec qui
était non mais en fait je vous le dis
parce que je suis là c'est le mien
celui-là donc vous pouvez pas vous
mettre comme ça voilà et donc je vous le
dis la place du milieu c'est l'enfer de
la pierre non mais sans déconner c'est
la pire tu as l'impression d'avoir de te
tais à côté de moi quoi le hublot il est
hyper loin faire pipi avec ton histoire
d'un coup là parce que la couleur
n'était pas baissé moi je le vole monte
en l'air normal un principe de l'avion
jusqu'à tout est logique et moi au bout
de 20 minutes j'y tiens bah c'est vrai
il y a la coup d'oie je mets un coup
d'oie je mets mon bras elle me dit
pousser mon bras j'ai mis t'intéressais
pas la coudoir ça fait 20 minutes qu'on
était rangé pourquoi maintenant tu veux
la couper ça exactement ton histoire
c'est comme vous savez quoi il y a des
mecs comme ça aussi si tu joues il y a
un jeu qui traîne il y a un Rubik's Cube
pardon puisque tu joues au Rubik's Cube
personne
[Rires]
frère je me kiffé dis-moi arrête je suis
hyper fort moi ça mais c'est ça
quand tu seras tout seul pour l'instant
tu me fais chier et le 30 mai c'était
pour qu'elle trajet en fait Paris
j'avais fait pas Paris Paris
doit c'est un peu long Paris
non mais c'est non non
c'est pas le pilote et le copilote
[Applaudissements]
avec des trucs là maintenant tu me l'a
dit oui vous avez les uniforme
insupportable
moi je demande toujours les places
issues de secours
c'est une année qui vient de voir la
meuf en plus elle doit je peux vous
parler de petite
sauveur de l'avion
tu dis je vais être le sauveur tout le
monde va dire Hanouna il est incroyable
frère la meuf alors
c'est vous qui êtes donc à l'issue de ce
donc et là il te disent frère ils te
disent si il y a un crash quand même il
y a un crash il te disent en fait tu
dois prendre la porte
arracher la porte
tu sais genre tout le monde avec les
masques à oxygène et tout et moi je vais
prendre la teuba je vais casser
[Rires]
de 5 secondes il va se cracher mais toi
tu es tranquille
excusez-moi vous occupez pas de ça je
suis là pour ça j'ai pris du sucre
secours je savais que c'était moi ça
frère tu me remets la porte tu vas la
mettre de tes cons comme axes et tu vas
laisser passer des gens frère non mais
arrêtez
là tout va le faire tout va le faire
qui va le faire frère sans déconner
t'embrassera total mais non et quand il
te dit aussi même les trucs franchement
les gars sans charrier il te cherche
regardez les trucs et tu vous a plu
comme ça
le masque à oxygène frère ouais je
connais je vais être en panique je vais
prendre celui-là tu es con frère mais
c'est une rassera totale et vous mettez
en oeuf comme ça quelle heure frère
mais sans rigolé mais c'est une connerie
si jamais si elle gilet en dessous en
plus il y a le gilet en dessous moi je
vérifie toujours
non mais c'est bon parce que en fait à
chaque fois la meuf
quand les meufs
et genre et ça se gonfle jamais parce
qu'elle dit bon là ça se gonfle pas bien
entendu
quand vous allez faire ça va se gonfler
non mes frères